ADAM CHAMPY: Hi, my
name is Adam Champy,
and I'm the product lead
for the Google Cast SDK
and the Cast integrations
with OEM TV partners.
I'm joined here by Sascha.
SASCHA PRUETER: My
name is Sascha Prueter.
I'm heading up the
Android TV team,
and this is not
my Twitter handle.
So whoever you message,
please be nice.
Also, who of you is actually
here for the session
and who is here because
this is a room with shade
and quite cool?
No hands go up.
Who is here for free devices?
Very good.
There are no free devices.
So we're talking
with you a little bit
about the living room today.
And Adam will talk about Cast,
I will talk a little later
about Android TV.
So heading over to Adam.
ADAM CHAMPY: Great.
So we're going to talk about
building integrated experiences
for the living room.
And for many of you, you may not
think the stakes are that high.
But let me take you
through a scenario
that you've probably
experienced.
Millions of people will go
home tonight or tomorrow
and turn on the TV.
And if they're
unlucky, very unlucky,
they might end up watching
five to seven episodes, reruns,
of possibly the worst
reality TV show there is.
And what's scary about
that is that you probably
have an idea of the show
you think I'm talking about
or you have three to
four candidates in mind.
We're talking today
about an experience that
should be much
easier for consumers
than turning on and
struggling to find something.
We're talking today
about our vision
for the living room, which
is unified by Google Cast.
Google Cast is a technology
that connects the mobile phones
that billions of people have
with entertainment devices.
Whether they're extender
devices like Chromecast,
or integrated devices
like Android TV, or we'll
soon talk about Cast TV.
What this does is it brings
entertainment from the smallest
screens that you have onto
the most beautiful displays
in your home.
And sound to the best
speakers that you have.
More specifically,
if this wasn't
a bit confusing for
some folks, Google Cast
is about the mobile experience
and taking mobile apps
and extending the content
to larger screens or larger
speakers.
So focus in on that if
you're a mobile developer.
Android TV is about taking
the full power of Android
and realizing it in a TV
form factor, controlled
by a D-pad remote.
Sascha will take you through
a lot of that in the Android N
updates in a few minutes.
The goal of Cast
experience for those of you
who haven't seen it
is unified by the idea
of a cast button, which takes
the apps that you already
know and love and adds this
extension to a large screen.
So if you press this
button, it takes the video
onto the screen.
Or if you press this
button, it takes the music
into your speakers.
And millions of
people love this.
What's amazing about
this too is that we've
enabled thousands of apps.
And if you want to see
which apps we've enabled,
go to g.co/castapps.
And these are the same
apps that users download
and use on their mobile
devices with Cast added.
So there's nothing else for
the user to do on the app-side.
For everybody in this room,
that's probably enough.
You could probably figure out
how to make all this experience
work great, but
there's a lot of people
who aren't at I/O or in
different places that
look at streaming as
still being too far away.
They look at it as an HDMI
port connection and saying,
I don't want to plug
hardware into my device.
Or they look at an
experience of input switching
and say this is a
recipe for disaster.
Because before I push the input
button, everything's working.
And when I push
the input button,
something else
happens and I probably
have a one in four chance
of getting it wrong,
because I have four
inputs on my TV.
So we took this message to
heart and worked with a team
at Vizio to launch the
first TV with Cast built in.
And in particular,
this is one of them.
It's a beautiful
P series display
and it has 4K casting as
well as Dolby vision casting.
And that's the first
integrated device to do this,
and it's gorgeous.
And we get to see them out
in the sandbox as well.
And what we did is we made
it possible for that same SDK
that developers use, that
cast, to enable the TV
to switch to Cast.
So as soon as you
push the Cast button,
instead of having to hope that
you're on the right input,
it's just a seamless
experience for the consumer.
And Vizio has brought
this technology
into their TVs as well as
their speakers and soundbars.
So today, we're also
proud to announce
the Google Cast for TV program.
Extending this capability to
Toshiba, Philips, Magnavox,
and Polaroid, to
take this technology
to millions more consumers.
What's amazing for the
developer community
is that you can now reach
millions of endpoints,
not just on Chromecast,
not just on Android TV,
but in a class of device that
integrates Cast purely, just
Cast.
And what's amazing
about this it's
that same cast when I talked
about in the first experience.
And many of these
devices, if not all,
will also have another
feature, which is the idea
that they can wake on Cast.
Where if you press
that cast button,
the TV wakes up without the
user having to do anything.
So instead of having to find the
remote control, turn on the TV,
hope to get to the
right input, your one
cast button away from the
content that you love.
So that's the consumer journey,
and enabling more eyeballs
for the developer community.
But what we also are
proud to announce today
is the new Google Cast SDK, and
this is our first major update
in a few years.
And it's based on a
lot of the feedback
that we've gotten
about how Cast works.
And one of the things
that you may think
is-- I've explained this
very simple UX model, where
you had a cast button and video
goes from a small little device
to a big device.
There's a lot of edge cases
and corner cases and things
to think about for the
developer in that experience.
And historically,
honestly, our SDK
made you think about
a lot of those things.
What we're looking at in our
new SDK that will come out
in the next few weeks
is us taking the burden
on implementing every single
one of the Cast UX guidelines
which are these corner
cases, and manage these best
practices.
Additionally, we think we can
really reduce development time
by not only offering
that, but also offering
the right abstraction between
what you're developing
and what the Cast SDK provides.
And I'll take you through
that a little bit.
For way more detail on all of
this, come to our talk at 9
AM on Friday, and if
you don't get up for 9
AM's on Fridays, that talk
will also be recorded.
So the Cast lifecycle
to go into a little bit
if you don't come on Friday,
is about four major steps,
three of which are done
almost all the time and one is
kind of optional.
The first one is
discovery, trying
to figure out do I have a
TV, do I have a Chromecast,
do I have an Android
TV on my network.
And that's trying to figure out
again how to discover devices.
The next step is actually
connecting to it,
launching what's
called a receiver app.
The third step is
then controlling,
because in the Cast model,
all video and all streaming
is going directly from
the cloud to the device
and you send small
messages back and forth.
What this historically
has been is kind of tricky
because if it all
goes well, great.
But if not, there's all
this awesome complexity
in reconnect, where
if you lose Wi-Fi,
if the user leaves
and comes back,
or you change different
Wi-Fi networks.
Some of these steps
could actually
be pretty complex for
the end user experience.
We also made it complex
for the developer.
We made you become aware
of every single one
of the steps of this process.
So our lifecycle became
your app lifecycle.
And at first, it's
pretty simple and you
may have adopted the Cast SDK
and copied some boilerplate
code into your apps.
And the first time you
do that, it's actually
pretty straightforward.
But if we make any
changes or any updates,
this became very, very
tough for you to manage both
from where do I
make the changes,
and also where the externalities
in making every single one
of those choices.
So what we've done
in this new SDK
is implemented a much
better abstraction,
where Cast handles both the
state transitions as well
as provides default UX for this
very unique type of interaction
model between a phone
and a larger device.
More specifically, we're
offering two major areas
against state management
and user experience.
In state management, you'll now
find something called the Cast
Context, which is
a singleton that
manages all phases of
state, from discovery
all the way through connection
and launching of the receiver
app.
We also offer an optional
reconnection service
for those of you who
don't want to deal
with trying to figure
out if there's still
a Chromecast or still a
Cast TV on the network.
And this is optional
because some people
have innovated quite a
bit in the space already.
So you can choose
to use it or not.
On the UX side, we
now provide as soon
as the user hits
the Cast button, all
of the different steps of
Cast beyond that press,
so that you don't have
to worry about callbacks
and trying to figure out what's
the state of whether a user has
gone in or backed
out of that flow.
We've also for
optional use, added
what we call an
expanded controller
and a mini controller, which
are part of our UX guidelines
alongside our
philosophy of saying
if it's in our UX guidelines,
our SDK should provide it.
And we'll see that in
the next few slides.
So the new Cast button-- and
you're seeing Android and iOS,
the new Cast button is
fully provided by the SDK.
And in Friday's
talk, we'll actually
go through adding
the Cast button
and getting all the way
through casting media.
The SDK in fully now
supports drawing and managing
all routes, including the
top level of knowing what
to do with the
background, and then
the next level in B of
actually describing what action
the user is about to take.
C, choosing essentially
a particular device,
and D saying well,
maybe something's
already going on in that device.
You don't have to worry about
any of those states at all.
You essentially have
a factory method
to say what color should
the cast button be,
and you're done.
The next part that we've
done is we've created again
these customizable controllers.
So at the bottom of
the screen, you'll
see a mini controller, which is
a persistent play/pause button,
but you can actually
customize which button
is most useful for your app.
So that this allows
the user to always
be in control of the
streaming experience.
So if you're live app
or you're a music app
and you really care about
skip forward or thumbs up
or thumbs down or
a heart or a star,
and that's the most important
button for your application,
you can put that in
the mini controller.
We also offer an optional
expanding controller,
which takes the best practices
of a full screen control
and allows us
similarly to control
the buttons that are present.
Again, both of these
screens are optional
and in both Android and iOS, we
can wire our state transitions
to your controllers
if you've already
invested a significant
amount of time
in figuring out the best
UX model for your users.
Across the board-- and I'll
use Android as an example,
we also provide the mini
controller, the expanding
controller, and lock
screen controls.
And these lock screen controls
also work with Android Wear.
So if you're just
literally a couch potato
and can't even
pick up the remote,
you can hit play and
pause on your watch.
This one last screen
is for those of you who
are trying to introduce the fact
that Cast is now in your app,
or have recently changed
where Cast is slightly located
or aspects of that, we offer
Android compliant notification
that says where Cast is.
and at first you
might think this
is pretty self-serving for the
Cast team to say cast more.
We would only do this, though,
if it actually benefited
the developer community.
And what we found is
in the apps that we've
tested this concept with, it
drives longer session times
as well as longer adherence
to the app itself.
So we offer this as an
optional behavior pattern
that you can call for
both Android and iOS.
In terms of timing, we're
going to be launching
this over the next few weeks.
The apps that you see
are full demo apps,
where you're going to be able
to dive into the code itself.
So by about mid June,
you'll see the core SDK.
In the middle of
the summer, you'll
have access to the fully
customizable controllers.
We're launching iOS
and Android first,
then we'll add and layer in
the capabilities for the web
sender, as well as a
new web receiver that's
compatible with all of this.
So with that, all of this
is enabled by the Cast app.
And I'll shift to here.
What's great about the Cast
app is that not only can you
discover content, but you can
control all of your devices.
And you can see I have a Cast
TV, I also have a Chromecast.
And the first device
that showed up
was a Nexus player,
an Android TV.
And to talk much
more about Android,
I'll turn it over to Sascha.
SASCHA PRUETER: Thank you.
Thanks, Adam.
So now talking a little
bit about Android TV.
I think this shows how
Google sees the living
room as one big ecosystem.
We bring in other platforms
into the Cast ecosystem.
We are actually making
sure that Android TV
is a prime Cast endpoint.
We're actually spending a lot of
time making sure it really is.
So one of the things
Adam already touched on
is with Cast being a very
mobile-centric approach
on getting the consumer
to the content on the TV,
with Android TV traditionally
being more of remote control
driven, like a
Leanback experience.
You sit back on the
couch, you just grab
the remote control
from the table,
and start playing content.
But also with Cast
built in, we see that
oftentimes in
families for example,
that the kids like to just Cast
the content from their iPad
or their Android phone
to the Android TV device
while the parents might like
to use the remote control.
And so the nice thing
about Android TV
is combining the
different approaches
to interact with
the TV, and also
give UX developers the power
to create rich new first grade
experiences on that TV device.
And one thing I
like to highlight,
and I won't spend too much
time on these marketing slides.
But one thing I really
like to highlight
is Android TV is
not something for TV
built on the outside of
Android bolted on top.
It really is extending the
Android the core framework
to make TV a first
class citizen.
That is important, because only
that way, you as a developer
have the guarantee that
Android API will always
be there for you and
serve TV content always.
So your app is not being
broken by an Android update.
No, with every new
Android version,
you actually got new features.
For the people who saw this slot
on the schedule and thought,
I need to get out of the
sun so I will sit down here,
or they were speculating
on free devices, just
a super quick summary.
What is Android TV actually?
So it's really a TV platform
like Android has always
been a platform for mobile.
Android TV is the platform
for TV devices, which
you can interact with
as a developer with all
the standard tools you
know from developing
for Android on mobile.
Same SDK, the same
developer tools, and you
can enable a bunch of different
device classes on Android TV.
Smart TVs obviously, with
Android TV right built in,
we see a lot of success
internationally with pay TV
set-top boxes.
So cable or satellite,
live TV providers
bringing their set-top box
to your running Android TV.
And so you basically can
get your apps on there,
but you also have all your cable
or satellite channel content.
And also, the other category of
course, streaming devices, game
consoles, things like
the NVIDIA Shield
for example in the
marker right now.
These are then also great
devices where consumers have
apps, games available to them.
And it's all on
the same platform.
So talking a little bit what
happened in the last year
also with Android TV.
The ecosystem is growing.
We have more and more
partners coming to Android TV,
and I think it's
a very good story
to see partners who
actually already launched
in the first year on
Android TV, now recommitting
new, and actually extending
their lineup of Android TV
models for this year.
So talking about Sony, Sharp,
Philips actually bringing
new models to the market.
But also, it's great to
see new rivals especially
in new regions like TCL,
Vestel, RCA, or Bayco,
launching devices on Android
TV over the coming weeks
and months.
And we also are quite happy
to welcome another new partner
on the Android TV platform.
You see that orange
logo there on the right.
We are actually really
excited to announce
that a new partner
for Android TV
is Xiaomi, with bringing
their first Android
device in the US on Android TV.
So Xiaomi will soon be launching
the Mi Box here in the US,
and it's the first
Android TV product,
and it's a very powerful device.
It's 4K capable, HDR capable.
You get all the high
quality content from 4K,
HDR enabled content from
YouTube, Netflix, and so on.
It has all these capabilities.
Comes with a nice sleek remote
control that is voice-enabled,
a Bluetooth remote control.
They will also ship as an
optional accessory a game pad,
so you can enjoy Android TV
games on your Mi Box device.
If you want to find out more
about this, starting tomorrow
at 12:30, we have some
people from Xiaomi over here.
So starting at 12:30 tomorrow,
Hugo Barra from Xiaomi
will be in the Android
TV sandbox over there.
And you can try out the device
in the Android TV sandbox,
play around with it.
Hugo will talk about the device.
You might have to
take a selfie with him
if you want to see the
device, but that's up to you.
Moving on from devices and
talking a little bit more
about content.
Because let's face it, in
the end on the TV device,
you want to have content.
We're really happy how the
Play store on Android TV
has grown over the last year.
We have lots and
lots of new apps
and content, the
games on the platform.
And over the coming
weeks, we actually
see a lot of new arrivals.
So we're really
happy to get ESPN
with a native app on Android TV.
We have additions like CNN, MTV,
Disney, Comedy Central, Crunchy
Roll, that will all launch apps
on Android TV over the coming
weeks, or actually some
of them even this week.
Also, more international content
was a very important focus
for us.
So we're really happy that for
example, Spotify is launching
their app on Android TV.
We have Deezer and so on.
So really the
ecosystem is really
growing also on
the content side,
and we are really
happy about that.
So you already heard
from rockstar Dave
this morning, a little
bit about what's
new with Android N.
And he showed already
one new feature in the keynote,
but I want to spend some time
talk about what are the new TV
related features in Android N.
So a big aspect for us was
when looking at Android N,
especially from a consumer
perspective was we
thought it was a little
bit too easy on Android TV
to get disconnected
from your content.
So if you're watching
something and you
have the video full
screen, if you just
wanted to look up
something, maybe look up
for some of the
content or look up
what other recommendations
you might have,
you got immediately
disconnected from content.
And especially if you are a
little bit of a power user
and you're jumping
very frequently
between different
kinds of content apps,
for example live TV and Netflix,
or in between YouTube and Hulu,
the system didn't
handle that too well.
So one of the things
we did was actually
introducing the
reasons as you know it
from mobile in a very remote
controlled friendly way.
So to see how that looks like,
let's take a look at the video.
So you know the typical
Android TV, Leanback
interface with easy
to store content.
And if you are jumping a
lot between different apps,
you're looking for
a YouTube snippet
here and then jumping back
to live TV, looking for apps,
recent allows you to
bring up all your apps
you have recently used, scroll
it easy with a remote control.
If you don't like
something in there,
you can also just quickly
dismiss it and then
jump to the app
where you actually
wanted to watch the content.
So it's very easy.
We spent a lot of time
thinking about what's
the right interaction model if
you just have a remote control.
You don't want any
special buttons,
you don't want anything that
is very complicated to use.
And so we think we got
to a good solution here,
and it will be available on
every Android TV and device.
Another topic, also
very much related
to what I said earlier
about losing contact
with the content,
or actually for you
as an app developer
or content provider,
losing contact to the user
the moment he or she decides
they want to look up something.
One of the things we
wanted to invest in
was also having multiple
content sources at the same time
visible on the screen.
So I have picture
in picture mode
where you can
actually while you're
browsing for new content,
still be connected
to what you're watching.
So to see how that looks
like, let's start this video.
That's great.
So we exported all
our demos into videos,
because demos always fail.
Yeah, next year, the
YouTube offline mode.
So as an example,
you're watching live TV.
You hear something that's
interesting for you.
For example, in
this, it's a report
about a game that was
just released on Android.
You think, oh
that's interesting.
Why don't I see if
I can find that?
And you bring up Search.
You search with Voice Search
for "Pac-Man," and you see oh,
actually I can install that
and play that on my Android TV
device.
But all the time,
content is still ongoing.
You're not disconnected
from what you're watching,
and we think that's a
very important experience,
especially with more and more
content coming to the platform
and be available to you.
So what we allowed you
as the developer to do
is basically enable
picture-in-picture
for your application.
You can basically pin the
video into a specific section.
You can add a special
button to the media
controls in the control
bar, if you choose to do so,
which can easily
switch to PIP mode
for devices that do not have
a dedicated picture-in-picture
button.
There are a bunch of
devices like Smart TVs
that already have a
picture-in-picture button,
but we wanted to
design an interface
that with every D-pad
remote controller,
you can enable this experience.
And you can really easily
enable picture-in-picture mode
for your app by
basically just adding
this capability to
your app manifest.
There's an activity on
picture-in-picture mode change.
You basically just implement
that and you're good to go.
Also, one thing that we have
driven from the beginning
is traditional TV functionality.
I know we all like
apps and we like games
and like to have as many
apps possible on your TV.
But still, a lot of content
consumption in the house
is traditional TV.
So from the
beginning, Android TV,
since Android L
implemented something
called the TV input framework.
Which handles things like
HDMI input switching,
like physical cable
tuner control.
And also apps can expose
channels via this interface.
And in L, it was just
simple channel switching,
channel metadata,
program guides.
We extended that in Android
N with adding time shift
capabilities.
So if you bring your
content into a live channel,
you can take advantage
of time shifting.
Now in Android N, we are also
adding recording capabilities.
So you as a content provider
with your channel input
can actually offer easy
recording capabilities
and expose those to the user,
like you know it from any DVR.
So to see how that looks like,
we take a look at this video,
So this is free-to-air antenna.
This is like some device
with an antenna tuner.
You bring up the guide,
you know all that.
By the way, this
is engineering UX.
I had to fight a lot of
flights to actually show this.
And fighting fights mean I
didn't ask our UX person.
So this is not the final
version that we'll launch,
but we will provide an
update to the live channels
app in the Play store.
And you can see all
the standard things
like recording management,
schedule management.
You can delete recordings,
you can schedule recordings,
just as you know it
any traditional DVR.
And as the content
provider, you can
choose to opt in and
provide this experience.
This here is an example of
how also subfeatures like fast
forward, rewind obviously work.
We have plug-ins for that
in our media controls.
And so very straightforward,
and you can try it out
as part of the
Android N SDK preview.
As already mentioned, we
provide a standard set
of features, a schedule,
start/stop recording, listing
recordings including metadata.
It can be managed
through TV app.
We, Google, we
provide one TV app
which is for example, on NVIDIA
Shield, Nexus player, and so
on, which is the
live channels app.
Some TV OEMs provide
their own implementation,
but they all support
the TV input framework.
And you can basically
as a developer,
if you want to bring
content into live channels
that you want to
make recordable,
you can add this by implementing
the new recording session
class.
It's described as part of
the end developer preview SDK
documentation.
Also, one of the things
we will demo it with
is we will soon provide
support for external USB tuner
as an open source
sample, you can basically
plug in the USB tuner
and antenna tuner
into your Nexus
player, for example.
You get the content right
to your Nexus player
and you can play around with
recording and all the stream
management I just mentioned.
We will provide that as
an open source sample
as part of the
live channels app.
Another really important
topic for us for Android N
was supporting HDR, or high
dynamic range properly.
So as you know, with all
the UHD, new UHD TVs,
HDR became a big topic.
It really describes
the ability to display
a wide range of colors and
in the right natural color
schemes.
And so one of the
problems we saw
is that there are a lot
of different HDR standards
out there.
So you have HDR 10,
you have Dolby Vision,
you have a hybrid log gamma.
And as both a consumer
and the content provider,
it's confusing.
Because how do I know which
standard I have to support?
If I have a content app
and want to play out
beautiful 4K content
with a format in HDR,
which of the standards do I use?
How do I even know what
the device supports?
So in Android N, we are adding
new APIs to support HDR,
and we are addressing two cases.
One is the case for
device manufacturers
so they can actually
properly plumb up
their HDR decoder in the
system and signal to the system
and say, hey, I support these
high dynamic range standards.
And as a content provider
for example, Netflix,
they can query
the system and see
these are the standards
that this device supports
and then make the choice
which stream to deliver.
And that could be everything
from the standard,
like the HDR streams they
have for this device,
or they can make the call.
Well, this device actually
does not support an HDR center
that I need, so I'm just
delivering a plain 4K stream.
We had to get HDR
capabilities API'd
so that apps can actually
query for the capabilities
of this device.
Some important
things to note here.
The decoder capabilities
will also be exposed to that,
and we have some
requirements around that.
HDR 10 requires HEVC decoder
to support HDR 10 Main 10.
Dolby Vision requires a special
HEVC decoder and hybrid log
gamma requires VP9 profile 2.
By the way, this is the
profile that YouTube
announced earlier this year
they will support HDR in.
Another important
topic, especially
at I/O for developers
is the Leanback library.
Leanback library is our toolset
to enable app development very,
very easily on Android TV.
So if you already are used
to Android development
on mobile, on tablet,
in any form factor,
we give you with
Leanback support library,
we give you a toolset to
very easily bring your app
from mobile to the big screen.
And over the last year,
we saw lots of developers
use our toolset, and we
got a lot of feedback.
So there are certain things
that they were missing.
There were certain use
cases we actually initially
didn't envision.
And we for once,
listened, and we
are providing an update to the
Leanback library very soon.
It's around the end timeframe.
And we add in for example,
support for custom fragments
in the browse fragment.
The browse fragment is one of
these things that basically
allows you to display multiple
lists of content in your app
very easily.
But we had a very
strict approach to that.
We had basically one thought
on how this should look like.
We got lots of feedback that
yeah, the browsing itself
would be nice, but
in my app, I would
like to have it a
little bit different.
I would like to have
different metadata
and I'd like to have
a different order.
And by building
a custom fragment
into the browse fragment,
that will help you a lot
without reinventing the wheel.
We also improved the
media player a lot
to support custom actions.
We get details in media
action specifically
that allows if you have a
very content-heavy app that
wants to display a lot
of the content metadata
and interact with that during
playback, that will help you.
And also, we make
branding easier.
So a lot of the feedback
was if you are actually
using the Leanback library as
a standard to build your app,
it was a little bit hard to
get your own brand in there,
make your app a little bit
different from the other apps.
And we did a bunch of work to
allow you to brand it easily
without reinventing everything
and building everything
yourself again.
For this, this is only
a super high level
teaser what's going on here.
There's a session this week, and
we'll listen to those sessions
later that goes really, really
deep into the Leanback library
inner workings.
So if you're a developer wanting
to develop for Android TV,
that's a great
session to attend.
Three of our developers will
go through a bunch of use cases
and explain a
bunch of these news
and how the Leanback
library actually
works underneath on Android TV.
So of all these new things,
how can you actually
interact with that?
As you heard in the keynote,
the Android N developer preview
is already available.
So you can download
that already and you
should get started with that.
All the Android TV features
are included as part
of the standard Android SDK.
There's nothing special for TV.
It is just Android.
So if you download the Android
N developer preview SDK,
the Leanback library
will be included,
all the new TV features
will be included.
And we also updated
the documentation
and some of the sample
apps as part of that.
Also, we got a bunch of
feedback on the emulator for TV,
it having horrible
performance, which
was valid feedback
because it indeed
had very horrible performance.
We updated that quite a bit.
We think it's much better now.
It's actually usable as a pretty
standard development tool.
You don't necessarily have
to use the hardware anymore.
And also, for those you
who have a Nexus player,
you can sign up or download for
the Android N developer preview
image.
You can download
the image in Flash,
or you can sign up for an online
OTA directly to the device.
And one important
thing-- we have a bunch
of sessions that go into a lot
more detail than this overview
session.
So if you're interested,
especially if you're
working on media streaming
apps, join the XO Player session
both valid for
mobile and TV today.
We have office hours
with a living room
with both Cast an Android
TV tomorrow at 10:00,
and at 3:00 PM the
talk I just mentioned,
deep dive into the
Leanback support library.
At nine, I think it's your talk
going deeper and introducing
the new Cast SDK.
Jay and I will
target 11 on Friday
about bringing live content
to Android TV also much
more detailed than the session.
And at 2 PM on Friday
is a great session
if you have a mobile
app and are wondering
how to bring that to TV.
How does that transition
actually work?
What are best practices?
What is the easiest way?
So that's a good
session to attend then.
We also have our
support communities,
developer communities,
you see the links here.
But I think with that, I think
we should open for questions.
I think we have
microphones somewhere,
if there are any questions.
I think they should
be on the sides.
I think I see one there,
and one right here.
So if you have a question,
come up, ask a question.
If not, I'm totally
cool with that.
ADAM CHAMPY: And just so you
know, our sandbox is literally
about 100 yards that
way and we'll be there
for good chunks of today,
tomorrow, and Friday.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
I have a question.
Can you hear me?
Actually, all this talk about
the living room about Google
Cast and Android TV.
I'm a former education
technologist actually,
and I'm wondering about
streaming interactive content
to the Smartboards
in the classroom.
Do you guys support other
formats than video and audio
for casting?
ADAM CHAMPY: So I can answer.
So can folks who
are leaving just
be a little quieter
for one second?
The main aspect of interaction
or a classroom aspect
could be served in a
couple different ways.
If you have a mobile app that
wants to display something
on the big screen like
video content or voting
from different
students in a class,
the Cast model is really
powerful for that.
So we could follow up or
join the discussion on Friday
and we can talk a little
bit more about that.
AUDIENCE: I'm talking
about custom content.
For example, HTML5 or Flash.
ADAM CHAMPY: So
currently on Cast, we
support effectively an
HTML5 player and a couple
different media formats.
I'm happy to speak with
you afterwards and go
into much more detail on that.
I'll join you right outside.
AUDIENCE: The Play store on
Android TV is kind of lame.
My app is buried
at the very bottom
and there's really no
way for people to get it,
because you just have to
keep scrolling to the right,
and nobody is going to
go beyond three or four,
let's say five
apps down the list,
because I guess you're using the
Leanback library for the Play
Store as well.
So is there going to be
any improvement to that
so that my app can
get discovered?
SASCHA PRUETER: I mean, now
with the Play Store filling up
with more and more
apps, it's the same way
as mobile a little bit, right?
You can't expect with
millions and millions of apps
to have every app being
on the front page.
No one scrolls through
millions and millions of apps,
so we are focusing more on
bringing categories more up
and doing some work
about featuring apps,
and also improving search.
But it is now a pure scrolling
model with thousands of apps
being in the store, becomes
less and less of a model.
What we're trying
to do is very soon
come up with a new
model around categories,
so that drilling into different
types of apps for the user
will be easier.
So discovery by
browsing categories
depending on what
they're looking for,
will be a little bit easier.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Is there a way to like feature
apps that are not Netflix
and like all the big
guys, maybe curate it
a bit and trying to get the
little guys a little bit up
there?
SASCHA PRUETER: So we have
guidelines if you look
on the android.com/tv, we
have guidelines, for example,
UX guidelines to be even
considered for highlighting.
Then again, it
depends in what region
your app is available,
what content is there,
what competitions you have.
We can't always only
merchandise or highlight
a very low number of apps.
So we are really investing more
into like category navigation,
and more discovery options
on the Android TV Play Store
and Search.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
SASCHA PRUETER:
Thank you very much.